thank you very much
mr president emanuel
vice president harris prime minister
trudeau
president carys and distinguished guests
it has been three years indeed since the
firm launched the paris call for trust
and security in cyberspace
the call's ambition has always been to
reclaim the internet as a force for good
and now three years on the paris call is
more relevant than ever
throughout the pandemic
indeed the internet has been a lifeline
for millions of companies and the only
connection to our loved ones for so many
of us
yet cyberspace has also become a more
dangerous place
with rising threats against our critical
infrastructure our democratic processes
and even our personal health and safety
including our children's
it is very good to hear from you vice
president harris that the united states
is supporting now the paris call
and today i am happy to announce that
the european union is also joining the
paris call for trust and security and
cyberspace
alongside our 27 member states
because our citizens must feel empowered
protected
and respected
online just as they are offline
many of the european commission's
initiatives already resonate with the
spirit of the paris call
and i would like to focus on three
issues in particular first cyber
resilience
second artificial intelligence
and third
platform's responsibility
this year
cyber tax have targeted crucial services
and businesses across europe
extending even to hospitals and the
entire i.t system for example of the
irish health service
cyber security has a direct impact on
the lives of all europeans
and that's why we proposed a revision of
our european cyber security law
we want to step up cyber security
requirements for essential sectors
and we want all member states to level
up
because our collective security depends
on every single link in the chain
on top of this
i have announced a european cyber
resilience act
to set common security standards
for connected devices sold in the
european market
this is one of the ideas mentioned for
example by the paris corps
our goal is to keep troyan horses out of
our single market
while contributing to higher
cybersecurity standards throughout the
world
my second point is artificial
intelligence
ai is without any doubt already changing
our lives for the better
it can help for example detected cyber
attack
or like you said vice president harris
it can support doctors in more precise
cancer diagnosis
yet for people to trust ai
we must also manage the risks and
sensitive sectors like for example
health care or law enforcement
or for example
employment
thus our artificial intelligence act
will focus on such high risk fields
and set standards for products on our
market
in the same vein i'm very glad we are
now working with the united states in
our trade and technology council
to define shared principles for
trustworthy ai
in my talks yesterday with president
biden at the white house we were
exploring this common work
and we all know
while authoritarian regimes are
exploring the potential of ai to monitor
dissent
europe and the united states
are joining forces
to put ai at the service of people
and my third point is on platforms
responsibility
this is the core of our digital services
act
we hope it can be passed under the
french presidency next year
if algorithms of large platforms
spread hate speech illegal content
or disinformation
those algorithms
must be changed
you know the reports that recent
analysis shows that if teenagers for
example type diet
on certain social media
the algorithm will soon target them with
videos that actively promote eating
disorders and anorexia
we cannot let this happen
it is our responsibility as regulators
to prevent this
and our digital services act will give
us the tools to do so
and i thank president macron for his
call on standing up for children's
rights in the digital environment
joining the paris call is another step
on a common path
it is a commitment to working with all
of you
to reclaim the internet as a force for
good
it is a commitment to making the values
we cherish offline
also respected online
so thank you very much for having me
with you and i wish you a very
interesting debate now